[Music]
and welcome back to another amazing
episode of the careful boys okay we are
extremely careful and we have in the
seat today mr ryan got leverage the most
careful too this guy a very careful boy
for sure very careful i'm pretty careful
titties and guns on his shirt jesus
now we uh you know heard through the
grapevine something about a mugging yeah
well almost not quite yeah almost yeah
so i was out walking
like a week ago like just to my
neighborhood at night uh and then like
as i was walking i was it was late at
night too don't go out walking name the
city name the city monterey park name
the mayor
i don't know the mayor right now not
mitchell anymore yeah i know what time
was that we need the details of it it
was like it was like 12 30. 12 30 12 30
yeah it was like it was like late but i
what were you wearing
[Music]
how short was your skirt yeah
jesus christ uh no i was just like
wearing it
i was just wearing a hoodie and i had
like my headphones on that's your
problem
you were asking for it buddy i usually
go out walking like around like the park
and police station and stuff just
because it's like close by but i was
like you usually just walk around the
police station at midnight because it's
also attached to a park so that's where
you'd also go walk around you usually go
like kind of late to go for a walk yeah
because it's like not it's like sunny
out it's not like that's a safe area
because you know what park you're
talking about yeah yeah exactly all
right ryan's mug people over there you
don't know if you know monterey park you
know where this is but i don't know what
it is the monterey park yeah the
monterey park of the park
um but this time this time
this time i decided to like go walking
just throughout the neighborhoods or
whatever because i was like oh it's like
whatever like i'll just go do this i'll
change up the my routine for the day
never do that shock your muscles that's
what spells
muscle confusion the muscle confusion
isn't walking
so i was like walking and then i hear
this like um
like loud exhaust and i was like oh
cause it's like really late at night
so now a cat is chasing me
so then as i was walking this like
mercedes with the loud exhaust like
pulls up like kind of beside me and i
was like not very inconspicuous as a
criminal exactly so i was like that's
kind of weird but it's also like the 66
so a lot of people have modified cars i
used to have like a modified car
something whatever this is 636 don't do
modified mercedes no they do it's rice
rockets well actually new new six is
just with the rich chinese people that
got like all the lambos and stuff under
the [ __ ] t-spots anyways yeah anyway
so then this this mercedes like pulls up
in the direction that i'm going like in
front of me and it parks and i'm like
that's kind of weird because there's
like nobody on the street at night like
it's like one of the sides like
residential streets and i'm like that's
weird and then also in the [ __ ] like
passenger like the back passenger door
like opens up like really quickly and
this like skinny dude like basketball
shorts like jumps out and then you know
when someone gets ready to kind of do
that like
to sprint at somebody they kind of do
like a little juke like getting ready to
like run so that he did that at me i was
like [ __ ] that i like turned around and
like sprinted like i sprinted like
[ __ ] fast down one of the side
streets towards the main street where
there's more lights on it's really rude
by the way that's very rude
just running away from somebody because
what if what if this guy just wanted to
run home to go pee what if he's like you
dropped your wallet yeah he wasn't doing
that he wasn't and he wasn't running
towards the house he was running like
towards my direction so i was like oh
[ __ ] regardless regardless of whether or
not he was actually trying to do
something or not i wasn't going to stick
around to find out like what that was so
i was like [ __ ] that so he said i have a
million dollars to give you
he's like let me tell you about your
stock portfolio options why they don't
make horror movies about ryan has to go
because he's [ __ ] already running
and that's why they never give him
japanese people in a horror movie yeah
except for the ones in japan oh that's
true but their ghosts are a little
weirder they live in your house yeah you
can't outrun them yeah yeah so i ran to
the to the main street called the police
and they like took down our report and
stuff but there's like nothing that they
could really do because it was like
there's no because you're asian do you
know that he was running after you um i
ran pretty quickly and i ran in the
opposite direction that the car was
facing on purpose so that way like if
they were trying to chase me like they
wouldn't try and wait so the car was
this way you're going this way were you
walking this way and the car was coming
up to you and then you went this way i
went the opposite direction and back
towards the main street yeah cause i was
like i'm not i'm gonna make it a big
enough pain in the ass for you to chase
me that if you didn't [ __ ] run and
then get some distance and go
no
first of all i don't have a gun first of
all what i first of all what i can't
wait for is one of those self-defense
channels to pick up this video and be
like actually we're wanting to talk
about that is actually wrong
active self protection
asp baby listen you're trying to square
yourself up with your attacker you're
trying to create a defensible position
so that you you have the advantage it's
very it's very accurate because you're
you're talking like you got chew right
now right those guys always have [ __ ]
tobacco in their shoes always got a
bunch but if they did review your video
they would say he did the right thing he
got the [ __ ] out of there i don't think
no i don't think so
you guys always have some gripe they'll
they'll never completely give you the
green light ever there's always some
slight they got for you i don't care
unless you pull out your gun and
actually shoot the guy first then it's
like when they rate it it's 10 out of
10. out of every example you should do
this
right now this is how you do it and also
i have a [ __ ] heart on right now i'm
going to take care of that real quick
so hey jim hey jim we're going to cut
here i'm going to take care of my heart
on
leave it in the video and leave it in we
don't care here can you please just keep
talking like that that's so funny i like
this steve i'm telling you i'm telling
you i watch these guys it's the [ __ ]
best they'll watch a chick almost get
raped like here's where she [ __ ] up
okay dude okay he's like let me tell you
something i need special forces okay you
don't exactly get invited special forces
you gotta work your ass off you don't
get invited
i love how when they don't know where
the video is they go we're gonna look at
the situation here it's probably brazil
[Laughter]
yeah
probably brazil they always say that and
it's like the desert yeah
santa it's brazil typical brazil it's a
[ __ ] it's a [ __ ] guy in a camel
with a gun
probably sao paulo we don't know see so
you know who are these guys what do i
know orange palm springs whatever they
have all these like uh critique videos
of what happens when cctv picks up some
breakdown robbery monday morning
quarterback everything
ever yes exactly but a lot of the times
too it's like some really fat dude that
doesn't even look like he could run and
it's like guy looks like he eats
meatball subs at breakfast lunch and
dinner dude well if it's that guy john
korea he was a pastor right no he is
currently a pastor yeah i think his
co-host is like an ex-cop or something
like that i actually like his channel a
lot because a lot of the times he's just
like i don't know why they shot that guy
like you had a million other options to
like get out of this situation and now
you have rounds going into like the
neighborhood and he's good at saying
when it's now an unlawful shot he's like
first shot was good second one you're
going to jail
cause like because you get one and if
the guy's like struggling after you shot
him and then you go up to his head and
you just tap on okay like then you're
going execution yeah but the first one's
like self-defense
once you stop whatever is happening once
he stops moving if he like dropped his
gun he's like okay you got me you got me
yeah but that's only if it's on camera
first of all your attacker has you at a
significant disadvantage
however secondly you your lips are
freshly moist they are chapped you could
offer the attacker a [ __ ]
about 50 about 55 seconds into the said
[ __ ] you shoot him in the ditch
you apprehend you apprehend the
attacker's weapon then you procure the
weapon you have now cleared it
you are not putting your finger on the
trigger that is poor trigger
man while you're stuck in this dude's
dick
these guys are the [ __ ] worst of the
whole interview first you grab his penis
and then you swap your hand with the
other hand as you slowly
grab your weapon and blast his balls off
you've now judged balls from his body
allowing yourself an opening for the
attack you understand
have you seen that video of the guy at
the ufc fight and the guy behind him i
was like grab his dick and twist it
oh everybody yells at sports events
good this is not a legal move you guys
leave but not i've been doing it this
whole time i almost did to that guy the
well at least you can i wish you could
submit that video of you running i'm you
running away just for them to say like i
love it what we have here is the late
model mercedes four-door it's clearly
sao paulo
tell by the japanese man running away
there are a lot of japanese people in
brazil first of all if you run like that
in brazil guess what people are gonna
chase you
i love that like why do you always say
it's brazil not gonna make america look
bad
yeah there's like a gas station an
article and [ __ ] god bless this country
son you should just start your own
channel where you just break down videos
your own character
with the character yeah you [ __ ]
america like manga hat goatee maga hat
ravens just ain't just dunking all these
yeah don't shed on me right here you
need flannels you need like boatloads of
flannels or those [ __ ] stupid shirts
to say stand next to me and you're my
friend forever turn your back on me
you're an enemy for life
what is that from the over the top where
like it's like sylvester stallone and a
black dude going like that they go like
this no [ __ ] predator
[Laughter]
i know dude those are the best shirts
facebook shirts man those are the best
dude i love the like parody shirts where
it's just like it's like a picture of
like that like the grim reaper or
something like that it's like i just
[ __ ] my pants
always a reaper an american flag
guns an eagle a wolf
yeah an assault rifle
[ __ ] and it should just be i never saw
combat
i was in i never saw combat i was a food
specialist
line cook u.s army
i know some food specialists and those
guys are cool but they never claim to be
more than they are
super nice people have you guys ever
been in an incident like that where you
kind of thought you were almost gonna
get robbed uh i had a guy pull a gun on
me before oh cool like yeah but but it
was weird because i was just i had just
done a play i was in high school you've
done a play i've just done a play was he
mad at your rendition of macbeth i think
he hated my i think he hated my
performance i think it was a review
actually it was just a review
at gunpoint
hey you're gonna stay here here's what i
think of you paul yeah i thought that
lady macbeth was not nuanced enough he
thought you did a good skipping
uh no so
so he uh yeah i was walking into a into
a cvs after
to to like get a monster or whatever
classic steve yeah i don't even know if
monster was out actually i don't
remember what i was getting at surgery
for myself right and then um i'm on my
way in and like this car pulls up and
this guy pulls out uh pulls out a gun
and he just like points it at me he goes
you know monsters not even out yet right
where's he tenant he's like he's like
i'm from the future
your liver will thank you later
he's like i'm from brazil
future brazil
and then like uh and then honestly it's
like an 80s movie where you hold it
there for like long enough where i'm
like i just freeze in the like in my
tracks like what the [ __ ] about to
happen and like my heart sings and stuff
and then he does that like 80s laugh
and then he rolls up the window drives
away
and that was it he just wants it what's
the 80s laugh it goes
[Laughter]
it like a bunch of friends are next to
him laughing but there was nobody else
in the car it was just him so you're
just one mental person
why i hated musical theater kids and
like [ __ ] you guys
what so he's like a flasher but he
flashed a gun yeah yeah yeah yeah just
to scare you by the way do i know that
was a real gun no
i don't know if it said nintendo on it
it could have been
it could bear yourself good i don't
[ __ ] know all i know is there's
clearly water that's splashing back and
forth in the clear neon casing
all i know is it was orange and yellow
and it had big [ __ ] these big blue
that's where they keep all the death
that's where they keep all the death in
yeah no
you did the right thing that was that
was where all the the deadly baby
killing energy
what if i was like he pulls a bow and
arrow on me
it's neon orange
little tip
it's one arrow at a time with the
suction cups dude i shot my sister with
it so many [ __ ] times it's crazy
to her hotness i definitely shot holes
with it
no no no if she's hot you don't go
this was here in l.a where that happened
no no that was san diego oh wow oh
surprising when you were running away
from the bad guy you didn't feel like
you would have you were hurting their
feelings did you strafe at least no
you're so inconsiderate dude i ran down
this uh down the street and didn't just
run straight you didn't go straight you
did you like do a couple like rolls
like a slide you didn't you didn't go
like
man i don't i ain't gonna judge today
and hurt their feelings no i don't give
a [ __ ] that dude is fishy as [ __ ] i'm
not gonna profile his vehicle and assume
yeah he's a gang member because of his
rims in the [ __ ] broom hey real
cocktail honest honestly i had an
ex-girlfriend whose mom got was getting
followed by a guy in a mall and and she
thought it was weird and as soon as she
was like trying she was trying to leave
and he was still following her and she
didn't she wasn't polite to him
thankfully and saved her life because
she started running to her car he
started booking it after her and if she
did this polite [ __ ] she probably
would have been raped or something yeah
and as soon i'm not kidding as soon as
she got in the car
she said she she's like steve i turned
and i closed my door and i like hit the
lock just in time before he's grabbed
the [ __ ] hand
yeah because she wasn't polite it saved
her life so i really do think [ __ ] the
plate in this yeah
because you wanted to be like you lost
your wallet or who knows i mean we can
we can figure that out later once i'm
safe that happened one of our friends
she was getting she was getting followed
and she she felt suspicious of this guy
that was falling towards her walking her
by her sorry and she just started
sprinting running and just screaming
and then the guy was like and he just
dipped the [ __ ] out turn the other way i
think that's why yeah yeah saved her for
later that's why it's good to live by
shoot first ask questions later
stand your [ __ ] ground hell yeah
brother
does anyone ever ask questions later
after they've shot
i mean you can't ask a dead person does
that actually happen it's usually the
pleasure of like what the [ __ ] baby
you like that
that's the question
or maybe like that guy's cool i was like
hey what was that guy doing on our lawn
huh oh he's the male guy
that's a male guy
new uniforms okay wow the bag really is
confusing i thought he had a bomb
i mean i thought it was a burglar with
that satchel
yeah it was just one of those like gut
feelings you know and something is very
like just off and i was like well if i
run away and this isn't what it is no
you gotta trust your senses man [ __ ] it
whatever then you're just some crazier
running who cares yeah exactly i was
like oh i just decided to do my to get
my sprints in what if after you ran by
he was like man that guy was fast as
[ __ ]
it was pretty good you guys see all the
the the
carjacking or all the robberies in sf
yeah it's [ __ ] wild that's why i'm
[ __ ] around with that [ __ ] what's
happening nsf
constant robberies like a really recent
uh video clip uh is showing these people
who have a lot of camera gear yeah this
up canadians yeah the canadians they had
a bunch of camp gear gear and this car
just pulls up and literally just like
while the guy's like packing his stuff
in the back of his car with the trunk
open just [ __ ] attacks them and then
they grab everything from the car throw
it in their car and drive off did you
see that smash and grab recently at
melrose or the jewelry store yeah yeah
they just went up and they were just
smashing up all the windows broad
daylight just collecting it
dude they had a sledgehammer to break
through the [ __ ] window you see my
judgmental ass would have always assumed
that people of lesser means
would usually be enacting these things
but when you see these videos and stuff
you're you are looking at people that
got like [ __ ] nice cars yeah or like
well it's smart because then if you get
real if you get if someone rolls up in a
beater then you're like that looks
sketch but if someone rolls up in like a
nicer car or whatever then it's like
then it's like oh you know another prick
parking in melrose
and he's like lost in the shuffle too
you're like which white bmw oh yeah hey
that's a good point some of them like
some of them are still those those cars
are like stolen too or like yeah the one
on melrose they stole the car so it's
like you know but if someone sees a you
know g wagon rolling down they're just
like like well that's the first car that
i would pick for a bank robber you know
did you see that video i feel like you
would have seen this one where the guy
he's he's in a jewelry store and it's
like after hours and he's chilling at
the register and then these dudes they
back their car into the door to break
the door down and then as soon as they
did that he's he he had like a handgun
on the table and he switched to his ar
and he just went by the board and he
took out the first guy and they all just
booked it why did he need his ar if he
had a handgun that's all i got because
it looks it looks better on camera you
don't actually need it i would say
one guy fan gun multiple guys ar yeah do
you know what an ar does
and how destructive augmented reality is
little handgun do you know how
destructive they spin bullets it
literally kills generations past you you
get to kill people you kill that person
and then you kill everyone in their
family past it before and after these
bullets just travel through generations
cursed bullets curse it both yeah
no it does the same thing a handgun does
but nobody [ __ ] seems to know that
anymore but you know what i don't like
is they never point out the positives
like how we can take care of werewolves
now and and finally we have something
with stopping power the last time you
heard about werewolf thank you exactly
because we have ars team edward and
because silver's so cheap because crypto
has outperformed silver so well
you can get some silver bullets are easy
easy
but onion stock is up i have a stockpile
of silver bullets i said onion it's
garlic isn't it bro i got a silver ball
bigger than my [ __ ] dick okay
you stock them on onions to like fight
vampires and they show up and you're
just like
you know they're just like [ __ ]
garlic
[ __ ] oh [ __ ] you're a werewolf he's not
a vampire oh [ __ ] i bought gold
i'm up a really high amount but damn
to go get a silver bullets and he comes
back with gold because he's like it's
more expensive so it's more potent dude
it's like no it's not gonna work onion
was on sale i heard a peter schiff
podcast
i'm telling you man this is gonna be the
[ __ ] in a hundred years
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you